et naples aux écueils kad merad
oui
j'aime les rats bonsoir quand tu m'as
comment tu m'a présenté kad merad
c'est marrant quand c'est en vrai nom
est mon vrai nom vraiment c'est kaddour
merad mais oui non en fait c'est simple
on fait kad merad est ce que tu connais
diable mais je connais par coeur diam's
âge et je suis dès ce matin
est ce que suggérait avec vadim
ouais alors laisse moi ce n'est pas
votre album le dernier c'est quoi ton
bleu alors qu'adp et on vous reçoit seul
d'abord ses 420 voilà et deuxièmement
comme acteur le coût pour un film qui
s'appelle les choristes de christophe
barratier lui où vous êtes sans olivier
est ce que vous ayez pas peur sans
olivier deux fois moins drôle c'est
clair on a passé des grands moments
récents que c'est le jour où il tue a
fait le pire c'est de là bas c'est
terrible c'est un truc c'était
magnifique mais ça je peux plus le faire
maintenant je suis acteur mais je suis
jacques gamblin vêtements dans ma tête
j'étais plus maintenant c'est fini
strict il est pas là olivier aubret dont
on parle et on peut le balancer entre
des trajets courts c'est un conte
qu'elle a déjà deux records porhel
désagréable et nauséabonde
soit vous avez eu raison de quitter ce
looser nos oliviers c'est une merde
lima il m'a longtemps une main longtemps
traîné il m'a longtemps empêché de bien
mais maintenant maintenant que tu es
sans lui ce soir il ya des trucs qu'on
peut révéler sur lui 25 centimètres et
demi à aya un médium mais ce que j'ai
entendu ça attention ça m'a choqué
d'ailleurs s'est passé chez nous on joue
absolument savoir si l'art de dire ça
quand même je pense que les mecs que ce
soit sacha distel warren beatty ou roger
vadim
on peut le dire je crois il avait des
grosses bits et buzz aldrin
et fort d un buzz aldrin est ce que ça
l'a empêché de marcher sur la lune et
déplacés pour cette visite des petites
soupes mais l'impressionnant un mois je
les ai vus gênant remake est allé sur la
lune
il n'a pas enrichi diot et j'ai bien
aimé votre film vous savez focus est la
bienvenue c'est ça c'est ça vient donc
vous êtes aussi des choristes
cad ouais dans un film de christophe
barratier qui s'appelle les choristes
avec gérard jugnot françois berléand et
vous donc je fais le pitch voilà j'en
rêvais peinard et 6 à 10 ans espère
faire sans titre et semble c'est
agréable
c'est un vrai luxe bon alors en 1949
gérard jugnot qui équipent rohff de
musique au chômage accepte un poste de
surveillant dans un internat de
rééducation pour les mineurs et dans ce
lieu règne un infernal système répressif
appliquée par le directeur qui s'appelle
fakih joué par françois berléand disons
voilà il vient aussi vous êtes prof de
sciences pas loin hélas hélas jugnot qui
est engagé donc les passionnés par la
musique et va créer une chorale avec des
enfants et cette expérience va
transformer leur vie
ce speech c'est exactement ça exactement
le beach et toute cette histoire est vu
en flash-back parrain des gosses qui est
devenu chef d'orchestre le rôle est
interprété par jacques perrin voilà et
votre personnage à vous c'est chabert
alors également au début du film
vous êtes du côté du manche à s'imposer
du côté du pouvoir de françois berléand
voila voila vous réfléchissez pas vous
êtes comme ça
l'éducation les règles et principes sec
comme un coup de trique et peu à peu
votre visage s'adoucit vous commencez à
sourire voilà vous prenez le parti de
deux juniors de clément mathieu joué par
par gérard effectivement il est il est
méconnaissable
j'ai trouvé fort mais il a une long des
rues qu'il a une petite mousse et
perruques c'est un animal morges
non non c'est un petit à petit rue c'est
ça qui est bien avec ce genre de
craintes qu'on a nous autres les
wisteria michel blanc gérard jugnot et
voilà est ce qu'un humour chose je pense
qu'on va bientôt pouvoir faire parce que
moi je postule j'ai vu ça mais de deux
derrière c'était zidane de derrière chad
dit regardez votre caméra pardon est dit
magnéto serge c'est serge khalfon à
serge khalfon bien bonbons les attend
akkouche ouest mais j'aime j'ai pas
l'habitude de faire des trucs comme ça
moi bon alors magnéto serge bravo au
[ __ ]